at t will delay deployment 5g near some
u.s airports planned for this week the
decision comes after the nation's
largest airlines warned the rollout
could interfere with aircraft technology
and cause massive flight disruptions so
the airlines have asked that the new
faster mobile service be banned within
two miles of airport runways this
showdown between the two industries
threatens to further disrupt the airline
pandemic recovery so for more now we
want to bring in someone who has to deal
with this on the front lines he has
dennis tager he is the spokesman for the
allied pilot association which
represents 15 000 professional pilots
who fly for american airlines dennis is
also a pilot himself dennis welcome to
quick take and thank you for taking the
time to speak with us i'm going to start
with a really basic question why is 5g
service
bad for airplanes and pilots
well it's not bad for airplanes and
pilots unless it's pointed at us and
we're bombarded by the signal and
there's no precautions taken
and that's what's happened here is that
a commercial interest and granted they
did the deal years ago and spent 80 plus
billion dollars they're complaining
about the faa not getting at it quick
enough the bottom line is the faa is
standing up sending out notices very
ominous and clear-wooded notices about
the effects of 5g
on our aircraft and it's not just about
low
low weather approaches
the altimeter the radio altimeter can
receive a signal and then when it gets
corrupted information it sends it to up
to 17 different systems on the airplane
like flight controls throttles thrust
reversers engine anti-ice the list goes
on from the faa and even the faa says
that these bad readings the pilot may
not capture them in time to maintain
safe flight and landing that's their
words to maintain safe flight landing so
this is a clear safety issue reliability
is second it's important to us as a
business but um this is why we're up
against this this commercially derived
uh deadline um but there's no deadlines
when it comes to safety so we're going
to continue to stand with the faa and
the airlines and the manufacturers here
boeing and airbus to say let's get this
done right well dennis help me
understand i hear you talking about the
control systems that it could mess up
but as a non-pilot speaker i'm not super
sure i understand
how bad this could potentially be i hear
you saying that landing could be an
issue i mean is this a legitimate safety
concern for passengers beyond just sort
of a flight scheduling mishap type of
thing
absolutely the reliability is important
to us and we would be standing right
with our company if that was jeopardized
but the safety feature on this if an air
to give you an example a a triple seven
a seven seven seven heavy large airplane
coming in if the radio altimeter sends
bad information that it's close to the
ground when it really isn't those auto
throttles come back to idle now it takes
time for those engines to spool back up
and the pilot has to capture that so
this is one distraction that can cause
an airplane to sink right into the
ground while the engines are spooling
back up so that's one example there are
myriad of them this is one instrument
that feeds critical information to all
of these flight critical systems so it's
not unlike the max different system but
where one bad bit of information caused
the cascading effect the tsunami of
other things to happen and we don't need
that we can get through this but we have
to test it and we have to do it
responsibly that's what our passengers
not only deserve but morally should have
and that's what we're going to do as
captain of the 737 i'm not going until
i'm certain it's safe and i know i've
got the fa in my airline standing right
behind me
i just want to point out that we've been
dealing with this for a couple of weeks
now and att has now says that it has
voluntarily agreed to temporarily defer
turning on a limited number of towers
around certain airport runways and that
is of course as att and verizon continue
to work with the aviation industry and
the faa to provide further information
about 5g deployment overall
one thing that i don't quite understand
is
we we knew that 5g rollout was coming
for a while now it's not a huge surprise
how did we get to this point where it
became a dire matter
in the final couple of weeks why wasn't
this resolved or addressed i don't know
last spring last summer
that's a great point and and you really
i saw the complaint of a t there
you know where you at labor union we
know how negotiations go we don't
negotiate on safety but what you're
doing is you're going in far and you say
well how about if i just take a little
bit more and then we're okay right
this is actually a t complaining about
the faa is exposing their lack of follow
through on this
now i don't run their company i'm not an
investor in it but how could you have
spent 80 billion dollars and not gone
through a fulsome run through on what
this would take to actually deploy
um
that that's their failing now granted i
know they're upset with the faa but
guess what the faa has stepped up they
have clearly communicated this and
they're like piles so like i don't care
about the drama it's about keeping
people safe so this one you know falls
in a couple of places but the bottom
line is we are where we are today and
those airplanes shouldn't be flying
unless there's a delay in this or an
accommodation that everyone agrees is
the right path for this we can get this
done but just jamming this through and
creating these fake deadlines we know
the truth that that you know i'll stop
there but the bottom line is this is a
business interest and we have a human
interest as pilots and that's keeping
people safe you don't want to stand at
the podium with me and my airline in the
fa explaining why your signal caused an
aircraft incident to happen and that's
dealing with it at the lightest level
let alone the human tragedy that could
happen and we're not here to scare you
but we're here to tell you how important
this is otherwise you wouldn't see all
these safety stakeholder uh
stakeholders uh talking like i am as a
pilot union um and uh the airlines and
the manufacturers and the faa it's a
rare moment that you have all of these
folks uh saying the same thing and we
should be proud of that because safety
is the number one priority and we're
proving that today well sticking with
safety i mean how do you get this
accomplished safely i know that in a
letter to the white house 10 major
airlines requested that this not be used
within two miles of airports
what could this roll out potentially
look like in a way that does keep keep
pilots and passengers safe
well we're pointing to the right
direction let's not forget that not too
long ago it was just hey we're rolling
it out we're flipping the switch now
we're talking about buffers uh the faa
put out a great uh information stream
about uh the the cell phone company said
oh we've done this in other countries
yeah but you did it differently it's not
apples to apples it's apples to rocks in
france they tilt the antenna down it's
much less powerful it's degraded it's
not in the same frequency band it's
right up against the one that my
aircraft uses um and it provided a lot
more fulsome protection
in the u.s they were going to do none of
that so we're getting there it's
unfortunate that we have to go through
this duress this drama to get there but
um you know this one i'm gonna lay on on
the uh
the folks that purchased and the folks
that sold it to them
but that's all just that's rear view
mirror stuff and the airplane doesn't
have a rear view mirror we just look out
the front windscreen and what we see is
an issue and it's got to be resolved and
we will get it resolved the commercial
interest will be addressed and so will
safety they will not they will coexist
they will not be separate
let me ask about how this is
working in other countries clearly the
united states is not the only country
that's dealing with 5g airwaves um how
are how's europe how is asia dealing
with this do they have a better solution
well clearly the example the fa puts out
is that europe in france uh the antenna
is actually pointed down they have about
over a minute and a half of protected
zone with the what is being proposed by
the cell phone companies is we'll give
you about 20 seconds of protection they
depowered it so it's not as strong as it
was being proposed to be put out in the
us the signal strength the frequency is
now buffered in france away from the
equipment
so they've done a myriad of things that
the french believe was the way to get it
done and do it safely now that's not to
say you know just because the french do
it though doesn't mean we need to do it
that way
we have a risk management plan we
commend them for taking theirs on and
executing but we in the u.s are going to
measure this on our risk management you
know in the us why we're so safe in the
navy in the aviation business is not
because we wait for an accident to
happen and look how to prevent it we
look for it before it happens that's
called risk management and we have
amazing professionals that analyze this
along with the engineers and that's what
keeps people alive and we're going to
continue to move
on that philosophy because it's worked
well full disclosure i i am guilty of
not turning my phone off necessarily
when we take off i'm sorry about that uh
pilot dennis but is that the same
problem is that the same service issue
or is that different than what we're
talking about here in terms of the
severity
that's a great point and that's called
being a human being i've been there too
i've been in the back and how
embarrassing when i'm dead heading and
my phone starts to ring when it
shouldn't oh so glad we're not the only
ones yeah you're not and that and that
but see that's not the issue in this
it's it's the cell phones can create an
issue but that's not
the solution all like make sure let's
collect all the cell phones and turn
them off it's the signal that's
bombarding the aircraft while it's up
there in the sky
that's what's affecting this radio
altimeter that cascades into all these
other systems so i'm certain the experts
would tell you well having a cell phone
on can can exacerbate that but the core
issue is that this the uh
the storm is out there the cell phone
companies are creating a storm that
covers the entire united states with
this proposal we're trying to help them
make it rain for their customers but not
create a thunderstorm in the path of the
airplane i'm flying
is this an att specific problem or is
this an att and verizon problem or is
this a u.s telecom operator's problem
i'm just trying to understand who's the
bad actor here or maybe bad actors the
wrong word who's the party that needs to
be making adjustments
well i it's clear at t and verizon are
the parties that bought the signals i
understand and so uh um you know villain
well i'm going to say coming into this
you were a commercial enterprise spend a
lot of money on a great product that we
all want to have we want you to be
successful because that generates
business air travel so we live together
but how you're conducting yourselves
right now you've created yourself you've
dressed yourself as the villain in this
it's okay you can take off the black
cape and join us and get this done
safely and we will laud your product and
we will log the safety margin and we'll
welcome you into this safety culture
you're an outlier right now it's not a
good space to be in i'm an att
probably 20 years
i want you to be successful i like your
product and i want verizon to be equally
as pleased but we've got to protect
people you know our interest you're
interested in a quick download of videos
and other services that 5g can bring i'm
interested in a safe download of
passengers to each airport that i land
at right and again verizon and att said
today that they would delay the debut of
new 5g cellular service near some
airports um
final question for you dennis should
people plan to not travel if if and when
this does eventually go through should
they stop flying
well number one for their responsive
they're going to not do it in some
airports it'd be like me coming on the
airplane saying hey some of our flights
are going to be unimpeded and some
aren't not a very comforting thing so
we're gonna get to a better place uh
passengers should be really as much
dramas in this intention and seriousness
no seeing all of us out here the pilot
unions the airlines the faa the
manufacturers we're on your side and
we're a formidable force we're a tall
wall so we've got your back and our
airlines are not going to let these
airplanes fly unless they're safe and i
know that i'm not going to fly unless i
feel it's safe so if the airplane is
there you're going to be okay and right
now we're fighting for you and we're not
going to stop and there are more of us
than there are of them
and it's not enough in them we can make
it all of us together but uh you know we
know how to put the gloves on and when
it comes to protecting our passengers we
get real passionate about it because
it's everything to us
all right well really appreciate you
joining us and giving us that context
dennis that was allied pilots
association spokesman dennis tajer
joining us on the latest with this 5g
service